I did not collect the poems written I
had relatively little to do with that
book that book was collected largely by
attorneys volunteered their time to work
with people who were detained often with
minimal amazingly minimal legal process
people who were detained at Guantanamo
and I would assume without knowing very
little about it there's a tremendous
range of people a range culturally range
of on short ranges of people who are
tremendously guilty of many things the
people who were innocent of many many
things the editor at the press that was
about to publish that book originally
talked to me about writing an
introduction and they sent me the
manuscript I tried conscientiously to
read the poems and I hope I correctly
recognized my own inadequacy I was not
gonna be able to write an introduction
to these palms you would have to at the
minimum you would have to know something
about Arabic poetry you would have to
know a little bit about these cultures
and they come from cultures in which
amateur poetry is a very important
component unfamiliar with amateur poetry
in this country I've taught at all
classes I've taught in prisons I don't
say amateur with a sneer in many ways
it's possible to idealize the country in
which there's a lot of amateur poetry
you know might be good for professionals
like me but I felt inadequate to running
the introduction and at the same time I
felt strongly about the abuse of civil
liberties
that military people were shocked no
people in military people legal military
people were bald and what was happening
there and these guys were just in a
tremendous fix the pickle they were end
and they've been put in by the
government of my country I didn't want
to just say oh I'm so sorry this is not
my field so I tried to write a blurb
that would least put my name in the book
and say this is an urgent book for us to
be aware of what you think about these
people they shouldn't just be sealed
away in apart releasing from a
government that we don't worry that's
part of Cuba ah if you read that in
vicinity sir Herodotus units I can't
figure these people I don't know what's
going on here anyway there they are in
this part of Cuba that we need some this
government we refuse to have anything to
do with and we must just forget about
them they need to be thought about and I
was speaking because I've been appealed
to be very aware that my gifts and
knowledge whatever they are as a poet
were not terrifically tremaine to the
contents that
you